ne dites plus pv mais fps forfait post
stationnement c'est une nouveauté de
cette rentrée 2010 8 ce sont les villes
qui fixe elle même les prix de ces
nouvelles amendes de stationnement dans
les yvelines le tarif s'étend de 15 à 35
euros à guyancourt en cas d'absence de
tickets derrière le pare brise
il faudra payer 25 euros le but c'est
pas d'obérer le pouvoir d'achat des
aiguilles en courtois mais c'est
vraiment qu'on est vraiment un turnover
parce qu'on est sur des zones où il ya
quand même certaines tensions où les
gens bougent peu et il les aider les
résidents sont pas mal plein donc on a
eu quelques remontées quand même à
proximité de la gare donc ça attire
beaucoup de monde donc voilà l'idée
s'était effectivement d'avoir un montant
qu'ils soient suffisamment dissuasif
mais non plus qui n'est pas qu'il ne
soit pas du matraquage une augmentation
pour gagner en efficacité
d'autres communes ont fait ce choix
comme montigny le bretonneux passer à 25
euros
trapel en cours à 35 euros dans
certaines zones plaisir maintient les 17
euros de l'ancien amendes pour les
automobilistes cette mesure est
dissuasive 17 euros déjà c'est pas mal
et en plus maintenant maintenance et
24/25 donc maintenant j'ai encore pris
de gaza tuant possible je paye suscite
le jour où avez vous mieux payés que de
prendre une prune j'écoute moins cher
c'est vrai que ça fait un peu mal de
payer 50 centimes pour de moins de 10
minutes
quand on fait juste en aller retour
voilà après bon si ça peut éviter de
payer 25 euros c'est quand même mieux
autre évolution le paiement de l'amendé
est ajustée en fonction du dépassement
de leurs limites de stationnement si
vous avez déjà payé 10 euros ils seront
donc déduits et si la police municipale
s'occupe toujours du contrôle à
guyancourt
les communes pourront aussi faire appel
à des sociétés privées